within days of the derailment the tracks
owned by Norfolk Southern Railway were
fixed the money-making cargo back in
transit
but life is not back to normal in East
Palestine Ohio and the town's 4 000
residents wonder if it ever will be we
came out that smell hits you right away
Gladys king lives in a nursing home two
kilometers from the derailment site the
air appears to be clear now but everyone
has been drinking bottled water ever
since more than 400 thousand liters of
vinyl chloride were released from the
derailed train cars in a controlled burn
on February 6th if they were going safer
than what they were they wanted derailed
and they wanted derailed all that
wouldn't have been the atmosphere and we
wouldn't be breathing all that
in his first visit to the crash site and
stung by accusations of a slow response
to the crisis Federal Transportation
secretary Pete Buda judge pledged the
government's help they're going to have
support from us when it comes to holding
Norfolk Southern accountable they're
going to have support from the EPA when
it comes to making sure they get
accurate information about the safety of
their air water and soil and I I think
they can have support they ought to have
support from a whole country that has
seen what they've been through
on Thursday the national Transportation
safety board released a preliminary
report that said an overheated wheel
bearing caused the derailment it's a
three-member crew correctly followed
procedures and the train was traveling
below the speed limit and investigative
hearing will be scheduled in coming
weeks this was 100 percent preventable
we call things accidents there is no
accident
it has been nearly three weeks and the
contaminated soil is still on the site
it is underneath those plastic tarps the
railroad company says it will haul all
of it away and set up groundwater
monitoring here residents say that
should have happened long ago do you
trust the assurances that you're getting
from the railroad company and from the
government half and half I know they're
not telling us everything because they
probably can't tell us everything but um
for the most part you know yeah you know
50 50. and residents fear the help they
receive will be short-lived and that the
suffering may be long-term
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera East
Palestine Ohio